people here are angry at un peacekeepers
they say have failed to protect them
this un Convoy was withdrawing to the
regional Capital Goma following attacks
by the M23 Rebel group widely seen as a
proxy of neighboring Rwanda
the Democratic Republic of Congo's Army
and the UN have failed to stop m23's
advances in the last year
people here have fled the fighting and
made barriers to defend themselves
started filing shots into the air and
the Convoy broke through the barriers
they did not comply with the
instructions we attacked them with a lot
of stones and we succeeded to stop the
vehicles and then the crowd banned them
down
on Monday people protested in Goma
against the Rwandan military aggression
Congo's government expelled rwanda's
Ambassador and recalled its own
ambassador from Rwanda
the U.S has it's concerned about Rwandan
military involvement in Congo Rwanda
denies it
now Kenya says its troops will join the
conflict
Kenyan President William Ruto announced
they'd enter Congo under the banner of a
new East African Community Regional
Force Regional heads of state agreed to
it earlier this year and it is
our responsibility to confront
criminals
terrorists
and all negative elements including amp
groups
not clear where they'll go and if
they'll fight armed groups including M23
Ugandan troops were already in Congo
when the agreement was reached they'd
entered a year ago it was ugandas and
rwanda's invasions of Congo in the 1990s
that led to two wars involving dozens of
countries from Africa and Beyond Congo's
vast mineral wealth was at the center of
it
people in eastern Congo have suffered
instability ever since
Congo's government says it needs foreign
military support rights groups and
political opposition say bringing in
more foreign armies once again will be
disastrous
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera